It's got an email that advertised this DNA test that's supposed to tell you about your metabolism
likelihood of being bothered by different toxins, all to help you eat the right diet, etc.
Is this the same information in the DNA test that you did for us?
Just not spelled out as much. And could we get the same information if we dug in that further?
Um, so there's a number of DNA tests on the market that will just test certain genes.
There's companies that will say, um, do this, do our diet DNA testing and charge a couple hundred
dollars for a diet DNA testing that they give you a printed readout. And they're really testing
maybe four or five families of genes, maybe a total of 30, 40 genes, uh, steps that they're testing.
And then they're making recommendations based upon that. Um, is that okay to do that?
I think it's okay to do that as a practitioner. It's okay to do that as a company. I just
think it's a very good value because it's all, you know, our test tests for basically all the
known steps that are available for anybody to test these days, which I mean, you know, you're not
going to get a, you know, you're not going to get 30, 40 steps. You're going to get, you know,
uh, you know, well, I don't know how many are, I think, test four to probably about 90,000 steps.
So I don't think that your, uh, as far as value goes. Plus, I think that some of these
read into it in ways that you shouldn't really read into it. For instance,
so if we look at your HLA genes, so your HLA genes are genes that can signify that a person could
be sensitive to gluten. Oh, does, does have a double illegal defects on your HLA genes,
mean that you have a gluten sensitivity. No, it doesn't, it means that you have, um, you have
genes that indicate that you could become a gluten sensitive, but it doesn't mean you have gluten
sensitivity. Just like there's genes for peanut sensitivity and mold sensitivity. Does that mean
that you are going to be sensitive to mold and peanuts? No, it doesn't. Um, that's why, you know,
you might get mad at me when I give you a vague answer on the genetics where it says,
oh, can I drink coffee or not? Well, just because I have the genes that would suggest that I don't
detoxify caffeine very well, doesn't mean that I don't. So same thing with, uh, then you could be
bothered by different toxins. Okay. So if I have a lot of gene defects on my pun 1 pathway,
that means, hey, I might want to support that pathway and, you know, what toxins are detoxified
on the pun 1 pathway? Well, pesticides and herbicides. So I probably should stay away from pesticides
and herbicides. Well, to truth is, you should stay away from pesticides and herbicides, even if
you don't have detox pathway defects. But should you support it, especially if you're dealing with a
serious disease like cancer? Yes, that's why we do make nutritional recommendations off your genetics.
But they're just recommendations, and it doesn't mean you necessarily have to stay on that the rest
of your life. Lord, is it mean that as far as from a food standpoint, Lord, is it mean that you're
going to have that you actually do have antibodies to that food? This is your genes. So your genes are
hard and fast. That's what it is. Now, your genes could get worse. You could have more
defects if you're exposed to more toxins. But you're not going to ever get better. And just because I
have a lot of defects, let's say, let's have defects done by HLA pathways. Um, and so that I go,
oh, maybe I do want to eat so much gluten. Well, there's not lots of other reasons why you wouldn't
want to eat gluten. Um, but so this maybe that's not the best example. Let's say the defects on the gene
pathway for mold and peanuts. Does that mean I don't want to eat peanuts because I'm going to have
a sensitivity to that? No, it doesn't. Should I, you know, should I take note of that? And should I
be aware of that and take note if I do have a mold sensitivity or that I have issues when I eat
peanuts? Yeah, I mean, of course, I should be aware of that. It's good to know these things,
but it doesn't mean just because I have a defector that that that is going to equate to a certain
ill health. And that's the only thing I don't like about a lot of the gene tests out there.
There's, and I mentioned before, there's Facebook pages about difference. There's,
there's literally an MTHFR Facebook page. And I belong to it just to kind of get an idea of what
people are talking about. To be honest, it's absolutely absurd. You talk about being angry at the
medical profession for not caring for their patients correctly. Well, honestly, I get even more
perturbed at the alternative functional medicine, alternative doctor sites that make these claims,
like, oh, if I have an MTHFR defect, I am, I know detox, I know this, and this is the cause of
all by ill health. And this is like, it's just literally absurd. So you just have to be careful of all
that. Okay, I think it's a great idea for anybody to get their genetics done so you can say,
well, this would be really good to be careful with this, be careful with this, and watch this,
and watch this. Though those things, you should be watching it and be careful of any how. But sometimes,
would you see something in black and white, it motivates you to understand that that could be a possibility.
For instance, the gene for lactose intolerance, if I don't have those defects, I have a chance
of being lactose intolerant. Well, maybe that's an issue that with your digestive system that you
should get tested. And maybe that will indicate maybe I just stay away from dairy for a while and see
if that calms it down. No, it doesn't. Well, maybe I should get a test done and do an antibody test.
So it could give you indications for other things. But it doesn't mean because you have the
brachogyne defect that you're going to get breast cancer. Nor does it mean that you have a pond one
gene defects that you can't detox at all. Or it doesn't mean you can't equate those things. Really,
it's more important to understand epigenetics, which means what your environment does with the genes
that you have. So just because I'm Irish, doesn't mean I'm going to be an alcoholic. But, you know,
genetically, maybe because I'm Irish, and I'm saying this because I am Irish, maybe I shouldn't be
careful about that. Maybe if I look at my family tree and there's a, you know, just about everybody who
is an alcoholic, I should be careful about that. It's wise to look at genetics. It's wise to look at
your ancestry. It's wise to look at things to help govern behavior if you don't want to walk down
that same pathway. But it isn't a, like a, you know, you're not, it's not said in stone that this is
now who you are. This is what you're going to become because of your genetics. And a lot of companies
kind of sell their products that way. And I would be careful of that. I mean, I could easily
say, you know, give, put together a protocol based on your genetics and say, well, you have this,
so you are definitely, you know, this is your problem. This is going to be your problem for life,
and you don't have any choice in the matter. And you can't do anything about it. You might be able
to sell more stuff that way, but it's dishonest. And it's, I think it's not any less dishonest than
than some of the things that oncologists search for in medical field is doing. So I, you know,
we have to be honest in our assessment of things too. So long answer for, do I think it's
valuable to do this? I do not think so. No. I think it could, it could influence you in the wrong way too.